Okay,
a very special piece of mail came today.
It is my official valid for the 2012
presidential election from Bucks County.
I'm voting absentee in Pennsylvania,
so I'm going to vote.
Here is the official election ballot.
You can vote party column,
which means everything down in the
Republican Democrat Green.
You're a libertarian party presidential,
Mitt Romney,
Paul Ryan,
Barack Obama,
and Joe Biden in the green and
Libertarian party.
Also have a state senator,
auditor General Attorney General,
a treasurer for Pennsylvania,
uh,
Congress congressional representative
and a representative in the general
assembly,
which is just the congress of
Pennsylvania.
So I'm going to vote.
Get my pen out here.
Not going to show you who I'm voting
for.
I know you thought it was going to do
it,
but I'm not gonna.
And then we're going to deliver it to
the mailbox.
Okay?
The ballot is complete.
Let's go deliver it to the mailbox.
Okay.
The deed is done.
I voted.
If you haven't voted yet,
you're old enough to vote.
Go out and get a ballot.
If you're out of the state,
get an absentee ballot about.
Make sure you vote.
I'm kind of sad I want to.
I don't want to wait four years to do
that again.
Whatever.
It was fun while it lasted.